I'm Toby I'm a bioinformatics PhD
student at the welcome Sanger Institute
I study the genetics of Crohn's Disease
I'm a dry lab scientist which means that
I don't go into a sort of a laboratory
setting I don't associate with the pets
or chemicals or anything like that I do
all of my work on a computer and it's
all data analysis making sense of the
work that others have done in the wet
lab
so in my group in particular on the
project I'm working on we have samples
coming to the Sanger from people who
have Crohn's disease the wet lab team
handle the samples process them and
produce the data that data then gets
passed on to the computational team we
try and make sense of the data in any
way we can we do comparisons between the
people who have Crohn's and the people
who are healthy to try and figure out
what the differences are once we figure
out those differences we can then
publish them online we can share them
with the wider scientific Community but
also we directly feed them through to
the pharmaceutical companies who develop
the new drugs I'm a bit biased but I
definitely think that I have the most
exciting part of the job we're looking
for patterns in the data and the data
can be very messy but when you see that
pattern hopefully you can follow it and
it'll tell you a story
I've always been interested in computers
and Technology since a young age
um and at school I really like science
and so I took triple science at ucse and
then at a level I decided to again take
all three sciences and then I studied
biology in my undergraduate degree took
some computer science courses where I
realized I really liked programming and
then I decided to do bioinformatics
Masters which is a computational biology
Masters and that got me sort of into the
dry lab setting Where I Was combining
coding with Biology and that was really
where I realized that was my passion
collaboration is key to the work that we
do in in my group when I'm clueless
about a particular problem there'll be
someone in my team who's who knows that
area and I just go walk over tap them on
the shoulder and be like can you help me
with my code and we don't just focus on
the work we work very hard but we also
take time out to chat and to just be
social they're all good fun to talk to
and good fun to work with
Maddox is an incredibly exciting field
to work in there's lots of data being
generated lots of data sets covering
humans parasites plants so many
different Avenues you can go down I've
bounced between Cancer genomics to now
Crohn's disease genetics when I'm done
with this I might move on to parasites
maybe work with malaria data from across
the life sciences that's just waiting to
be analyzed very exciting to know that's
all out there
everything that we do in our group is
done with the idea of developing
Therapeutics to help people who have
Crohn's disease and it's very rewarding
to know that I can do something that I
not only really enjoy but is also
beneficial to the world
science is incredibly creative you need
to be thinking of new ideas pushing
boundaries you want to be the person in
the room who comes from a different
background who can think outside the box
you've Googled away and you can't find
the answer so you need to come up with
the answer yourself and put out that
sort of new solution that no one's ever
done before
[Music]
foreign